c'est même pas ce que ça va faire moi
j'ai plutôt la sensation que ça va ça va
ça va me défoncer ces produits là c'est
par hasard ça tu fais attention to hope
en ce moment là bas on angoisse ou pas
au début je faisais genre mais en vrai
dire que moi j'ai une copie d'un as tu
l'as vu toi moi et moi je lui ai alors
comment quand et comment tester dans le
mal à vraiment oued ou graves doivent
exploser explosé de fatigue fatigue je
dormais 16h14 est entré dans mes deux
heures mais non quoi la nature
non mais c'est bien que tu en parles
parce que pour les jeunes qui nous gagne
à quel âge nasa toi moi j'aime ne seront
pas là donc été très mal à 27 ans donc
la mairie non combien d'heures comment
lutter remis rapidement quand un jour
quand même qu'un jour j'ai négligé je me
suis dit c'est impossible bien sûr le
mois mais en vrai c'est un jour il ya
mon quotidien as tu as vu il mange des
pâtes et lui la vie il avait ça la leçon
moi ce qu'il est venu y mange de tout et
je crois j'ai sa championne gouges dit
arrête et moi au moment et je me moque
de lui en vrai je fais une cuir gp le
goût je dis c'est quoi ça et après
cholet dans la boue j'ai vu j'ai michel
douce à rien j'ai compris les jeunes qui
nous regardent dit parce que regarder au
début il a jonglé d'année